i actually think a lot of the reason why
great stuff gets built is because it's
kind of irrational at the time
but so it kind of selects for the people
who care the most about it the things
that break your heart if you choose can
open your heart when do you quit you
quit when you don't love it anymore
wanna be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you too
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn the seven
rich people habits that you need to try
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with habit number
one have discipline with warren buffett
you don't need 150 iq to do what i do
thank god you know you don't need 140
you know 135 you may need 115 or
something like that and
and but you do need discipline
you have to wait until you see the fat
pitch to swing at
because investing is a no-call strike
game you know if i were a baseball
player and i only like pitches
two inches above my navel
you know some guy could learn that and
he could pitch me you know three or four
inches below that and i get called out
on strikes because i never find a pitch
i like
you can get call out on strikes in
baseball
you have to you have to swing at pitches
that you you don't even necessarily like
particularly after the count gets to two
strikes
in business
you don't have to swing at anything you
can sit there and
the paper says general motors at 68 or
it says general electric at 115 or so
general dynamics at 63.
and if you don't like those prices you
don't have to swing you can wait there
day after day after day after day and
there are no called strikes
now when you swing when you decide to
buy something
then you know if you swing and miss it's
a strike but
it's a marvelous game to be in because
there are no called strikes and you can
simply wait for that one time
in a month or six months or a year or
two or three years when you really know
what you're doing where you like the
price or you like the people running the
business
and then you swing and you only need a
few swings in your lifetime habit number
two stop making excuses with robin
sharma i was in johannesburg a little
while ago and i went through the the
airport
and i went to the men's room or washroom
or bathroom however you want to call it
and so i walked in to the men's room and
the first thing i hear is welcome to my
office
and this was the janitor at the
johannesburg
men's room that's funny who who
janitorized or i'll make up a word
cleaned the men's the toilets like
mozart composed music
now that man has no money that man
probably has very little education
that man is judged by the world as
having an unimportant job right and that
man is a hero could be a hero to
millions of people why because he
actually saw himself as an ambassador to
south africa and he his passion was was
palpable in his visceral commitment to
doing work at the highest level
was like you don't see even from the
ceos and all i'm saying is
even the person in the
with the broken heart the person who's
down on their knees whether they see it
or not they have a choice to rise above
their circumstances and leadership in
humanity is a testament to the people
who have done it i mean you re read the
group you look at mandela you know 27
years in imprisonment when his son died
he wasn't allowed to attend the funeral
of his own son he said that was the one
of the great pains of his own of his
life
and what did he do
the victim looks at something like that
torture and says i am broken
and they give up and they spend they
close their heart they close their mind
they close their creativity and they
blame the rest of their life on what
happened to them but mandela what he
chose to do was to use it as an
opportunity because
actually
the things that break your heart if you
choose can open your heart
and
fear the world says fear is bad fear is
only an opportunity for bravery training
and what he did was he used those 27
years of torture to open his himself
mentally physically emotionally and
spiritually to the point where when he
was released and became the president of
south africa he invited his jailers to
sit in the front row at his inauguration
and he was asked why and he said because
if i don't i'm still gonna i'd still be
in prison and that's a long way of
saying but you know we do make excuses
because we are very good at
self-deception because if we actually
had to face the responsibility of
playing with our business in the world
we'd have to let go of our addiction to
our excuses and and leave what's safe am
i making sense no totally no you're
totally you'd have to leave what's safe
i mean we are addicted to crisis
sometimes it makes no sense we are
addicted to pain
and we'd have to actually leave the pain
to go out to the possibility of pleasure
and joy and greatness
and believe it or not that frightens us
right so we make these excuses and then
we blame people oh joe or robin i don't
like the way he looks i he he speaks
differently but subconsciously as you're
suggesting those are just our protective
mechanisms
to avoid
owning the responsibility of our
brilliance habit number three believe
with jamie kern lima i also knew that
like of course i'd have to work really
really hard if i was ever gonna make it
of course i'd have to get back up every
time i got knocked down on the journey
but i knew if i was gonna make it like
the most important thing came down to me
believing that i could
and for me
you know
and here's the thing a lot of times we
hold ourselves back because we say
things to ourselves like oh i'm not
qualified or oh i feel this like dream
on my heart to whatever it is launch a
podcast whatever it is but it's like oh
but i'm you know don't know how and i
don't know i have no connections and all
the things we tell ourselves and
for me
in a way it almost made no sense that i
created a beauty company right and
just the idea of it because i didn't
know anything about it i knew no one in
the industry but every time i get still
like for me
um and you know no matter what people
believe whether it's they're hearing the
universe talk to them or god talk to
them like for me i hear it through my
own intuition and my own gut instinct
habit number four simplify and commit
with grant cardone the idea here is look
commit
okay and this is the problem with the
schooling system everything's got to be
figured out first i got to read the
instruction first like nobody really
does read this i never read this i wrote
an article about it i don't read any
instructions you know and so
i mean i can't i can't read them because
they're so small
so so uh and even when i could read them
i'm like i don't want to read the
instructions can't they make this
simpler yeah so and that is the premise
there yeah can't it just be simpler yeah
and and the way to make it simple is and
we see this happening today i mean this
is happening on a global scale where
picking a car up now is simple
pick me up
it's crazy i don't have to put the
address in it should locate where i am
car picks me up i put in the destination
tells guy where to go you don't even
need to pay for it either it's already i
don't have to set up like simple you
guys got everything should be simplified
and the way to simplify things i
remember mercedes-benz years ago i heard
about this when they had first figured
out how to put a drop back a hard top uh
convertible into the trunk they had
never they couldn't figure it out it
used to be these old you know they'd
hang them up in the garage and take them
off and it was like very laborious
and somebody at mercedes-benz said
don't tell me what it's going to cost
tell me when it's done
just get it done no matter what this is
how the elon musk are thinking today you
know this is why apple keeps creating a
crazy product while this will go away
somebody's going to come along one day
and say get rid of the phone
and i still want to communicate yeah and
it'll probably be on a headset more like
this we'll probably we'll probably go in
here right where i'm popping i mean the
watches yeah they're they're moving
there right it's crazy
so to where i don't even need a watch i
won't need anything it's like okay i
want to call blah blah blah we're moving
in that direction of less and faster and
simpler so the way the human being does
that he's in brisbane this part of the
gold coast
i got to get down there he's committed
he doesn't figure he he just gets a
flight
no research no no you weren't
researching it last night no not at all
if you don't know if you didn't know
about this last night you'd have been
you'd have been doing work about it last
night planning negotiating with the
airlines when you get compressed on time
and you've got a commitment you're like
i got to be there at 2 30 everything
works out
yeah as i was walking out my my
assistant she goes oh where where are
you going to stay
and i was like
book me a place we're close to you know
to the park or where you're staying put
that out but um we're on this trip we
went to tokyo
because things don't work out as planned
anyway yeah so i'm not saying go through
life unplanned i have 500 employees so
there's got to be some planning there's
got to be is that stretched over europe
it doesn't need to be me doing the
planning though yeah
like i need maybe i need somebody else
to do that
i don't have to do that no i just need
to know where i want to go so we were
coming to sydney i knew i had this
commitment with success resources to
come here and do these events good tell
me when the events are bang bang bang
um okay i got to get there right so a
week ago i'm like okay hey lanny i
called my pilot
i want to let route to sydney but
let's stop in hawaii
uh let's go to kauai
uh kids have never been there we'll stay
there for three days acclimate for a
second and shoot down to sydney i had
enough data to know that i would need to
do a route like that storm comes in
i can't get i can't for some reason i
can't get a the place i want in kauai
storm comes across the south the pacific
and
uh lanny said hey we might want to be
careful with this storm coming down
there i said okay well let me just let's
reroute to fiji double storm pops up
double-headed cyclone
okay in our path he's like grant we
can't go that way we'd have to go all
the way around this storm i said no we
don't go to tokyo
now the point of that story is look just
keep moving forward keep moving in a
direction that you want to go to we go
to tokyo i made all these friends in
tokyo i would have never done that but i
was committed to going to sydney
and and so again commit move in the
direction that gets you closer to where
you're going to go hey man how you doing
buddy good how are you you got a book
coming out don't you uh you just came
out
where can people get it
get it on amazon easiest spot built to
serve right there
let's go man if you guys don't know evan
follow evan carmichael he's got a new
book out build a server go grab it today
at amazon
there's a good dude right here habit
number five care the most about it with
mark zuckerberg i spent a bunch of time
analyzing and reflecting on why
it was that we were even able to do it
because
all
like all reasons suggest that we
shouldn't have been able to do it right
because all these other companies had
way more engineering power and um
and and servers and time and money and
all the stuff and i actually think that
this is a pretty instructive thing for
anything that you want to go do because
this is the same property is going to be
true for anything that you guys start is
that someone else is going to have more
resources and be able to do it the
reason why i think we actually ended up
being the ones doing it is because we
just cared way more about it than
everyone else right so
there were always projects at some of
these other companies that were these
hobbies but
we always thought that it was this
really important thing and really just
like felt in our gut in our heart that
we wanted to do it and you know early on
there were always these skeptics saying
that oh this can't be a business we
didn't actually care that much about it
being a business early on uh but a lot
of the reason why bigger companies
didn't invest in it was because it
wasn't clear that there was a model that
would work for it it seemed like a bad
idea yeah and
i actually think that that's true for a
lot of the best ideas where it is that
it's not that someone else can't do it
they actually can and the odds are
stacked against you but i think often
that belief in the fact that you just
care so much about what you're doing is
the only thing that kind of drives you
to do it and you know to be honest that
kind of drives me to this day i mean one
of the the big emphasis uh points for
the company right now
is internet.org and you know for a while
we had this rallying cry of can we
connect a billion people um and you know
when we started talking about that we
thought that was crazy right it was way
bigger than any service in in the world
that had been built and you know it was
10 digits long right it's like you know
it just it felt crazy we'd never get to
that but then the thing is as we started
to actually get closer to that we took a
step back and like all right well our
mission isn't actually to get one in
seven people in the world to be
connected it's we want to connect
everyone so it's um it's a big issue
that only around a third of the people
in the world have access to the internet
and that's something that we think that
we can do something about and similar to
early facebook we don't there's no
business model around this i mean all
the people who have all the money in the
world i mean it's not necessarily a fair
thing are already the people who are on
facebook right it's in the first you
know seventh of the world um but we just
believe really strongly it's like this
is what we are here to do um this is
what our company cares about i care
about it the team cares about it our
culture cares about it so we're just
gonna keep pushing on it and i actually
think a lot of the reason why great
stuff gets built is because it's kind of
irrational at the time
but so it kind of selects for the people
who care the most about it doing it
habit number six be extremely prepared
with tony robbins people ask my wife all
the time what's something about tony
that nobody knows and she says the level
he prepares so that was ray dalio i know
i got a chance to be with
literally the da vinci of investing most
average people never heard his name but
right you have to have a ten years ago
jeff a five billion dollar net worth and
he had to give him a hundred million to
start with for him to talk to you right
today he won't talk to you and take your
money how much money you have he's he's
closed his fund out he won't he won't do
a dime more so to do that
i i couldn't i couldn't consciously walk
in and just say okay i've read
everything it's available i had to watch
every video there's only a few out there
i had to read every piece i had to like
tear it apart and see if i could
understand his entire structure of
investing so that when i was there i
could ask questions no one else has
asked before and as a result he actually
shared with me he's averaged a 23 return
for 21 straight years
billions and billions and billions of
dollars smartest man one of the smartest
man alive in that area and because i
understood so much we could pitch and
catch you know most people you know you
can just they just they can just throw
the ball right but i need i want to be
able to throw the ball and have you
throw it to me and throw it right back
to you right that's where we get
something that's really exciting and
because i prepared that level he was
saying to me after he goes you know this
better than anybody i know and he's so
it opened him up more and you talked to
me in more detail in the end
he actually gave me a strategy
that i said to him i said look i said
ray
i said you're one of the most generous
men i know
i said you've just given me this
incredible strategy but the strategy was
like explaining why most people lose
money and here's how he's made money in
every market right pretty complex
strategy and i said the strategy is
great but it's kind of like you told me
you want to build a chocolate cake get
some chocolate you know get some sugar
you can tell me the amounts i mean the
amounts are everything right you get the
right amounts and he goes tony i can't
give you that that's my secret sauce and
i said ray you can give it to me because
i can't he goes that's my that's what i
get you know that's why you know i get
the money i do i said no you don't you
haven't taken money for 10 years
i said you're going to give away half
your net worth anyway i said you just
got done telling me the average guy is
never going to do this help me out give
me your secret sauce right and i got him
laughing he goes well tony it's kind of
complex i said i'm going to take a
complex and making it simple he goes
well i use leverage i said create one
without leverage so the average guy
could do it right and then i got this
chilled on the back of my spine when he
said well it wouldn't be perfect i said
your idea not perfect it's not better
than anybody else on earth i said right
tell me and then i took out a pen and i
said tell me the numbers right he looked
at me goes
well let's try this and he starts to lay
this thing out so when i'm done i can
feel the vibration in my body like i got
something nobody's got that i can give
to the world that'll be extraordinary
and i go he goes go test that he goes
don't when people talk about testing
they look back five years or ten years
he said
but the past doesn't equal the future
that way but if you were to test
something over 75 years
the entire modern time of history that's
what you should test that formula back
test it for 75 years come back tell me
what you get
85 of the time it's for 75 years think
of how much the world has changed the
last 10 years or 20 years 85 of the time
it makes money
the 15 of the time it didn't
the maximum drawdown in 75 years was not
20 like you've seen at 30 or 40 you've
seen in the marketplace over the years
it's 3.9 percent the average loss is 1.7
average gain is 10 so if you could go to
vegas and you could be right 85 of the
time and when you lost only lose you
know one percent 1.7
how you'd be you'd be investing a little
bit you'd be gambling a little bit right
so he gave that to me so i got those
types of things because i was so
prepared and so when i go to do an
audience a big audience like i do my
date with sd seminar people do 20 pages
of homework and i read all that for a
couple thousand people i won't remember
their faces i remember it's in my brains
when somebody stands up something inside
me recognizes the pattern or recognizing
this the pattern that multiple people in
the room need to deal with and my brain
clicks in and makes it happen so i
believe
you know garbage and garbage out as
simplistic as it is that if you keep
putting unbelievable quality amount in
when it's time for you to cash that
spiritual emotional
physical financial business check and
ain't going to bounce because you've
been making deposits and you have plenty
to give you're not you're not just
winging it to see what happens so i'm
intense about that but i also love it
because it just i'm always growing too
because i'm always learning more than i
need to teach anybody else and habit
number seven the last one before some
very special bonus clips is be
persistent with john legend a lot of
people want to be stars so the labels
are in a position where they have to and
should say no to most people that come
into their door and they need to be
really sure about you before they sign
you
so
they said no to me a lot they said no to
me even the label i'm signed to colombia
sony uh
turned me down
you know
like a year or so before i got signed
so
it just shows you that you have to be
persistent
you have to
keep trying to get better
learn from your criticisms and
uh
and and then uh
just
play to win and uh that's what that's
what i was doing now i've got a really
special bonus clip that i think you're
going to enjoy but before that it's time
for the question of the day i want to
know what was your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week the science
says that when you just watch a video
you get motivated to get inspired you
have a 35 chance of following through on
your goals 35 that's not enough that's
not enough just to get motivated believe
nation we're here you're here today
matters you're an action taker
when you commit to a plan of action of
when and how you're going to follow
through when you write it down you have
a 91 chance of following through and
when you commit publicly to somebody
else it jumps to 95 chance from 30
something percent to 95 chance of you
following through believe nation we need
to make this happen so question of the
day your single biggest takeaway from
this video and your plan of action
specific for the next week put it down
in the comments below and i'm going to
show on screen
sometime next week to celebrate you
when do you quit you quit when you don't
love it anymore if you quit now but you
still love it you will regret that
decision the rest of your life you'll
constantly wonder what if i just gave it
one more day one more week one more
month you might have to slow down and do
something else to survive but you have
to keep going if you still love it so i
look at my early days as a youtube
creator and you can go back on my
channel and see how
awkward i was and nervous i was and my
first video i'm sitting down in the suit
and the tie and
and i'm sweating and i'm trying to
memorize my lines and took me all day to
make one video most of my lines were me
reading because
i couldn't memorize the entire script
and i was so afraid of not having to be
perfect with my lines and so i read most
of it and had b-roll on top of it but
still it took me a whole day just to get
some of those lines out on cameras like
take after take after take after take
after take and when i started
on paper it looked like a stupid idea i
had no video background i was i'm i'm
introverted it doesn't come across now
but i'm introverted i don't like being a
center of attention i don't go in and
talk to people and introduce myself i
don't like the camera being on me i
don't like being in a spotlight it
doesn't doesn't make me feel amazing
about myself i don't crave it i'd much
rather be at home by myself you know
with my wife that's super comfortable
for me that's easy so when i started it
was just an
and even though i wasn't very good at it
i just loved it
i don't know i liked it i'm a visual
learner
and i think people are built to serve
right and
i struggled so much as an entrepreneur
that i wish there was more content for
entrepreneurs that was visual and that
modeled success bill gates saved my
company not not me talking to him or him
investing in my business just his story
how he started i applied and that
started growing my company and i wish
there were more resources telling the
stories of successful famous
entrepreneurs that you could learn from
one just get inspired to say wow look
what they can do but two also to get
specific ideas to help you grow your
business and it didn't exist and so i
thought i'm gonna go make it right
typical entrepreneur nothing exists in
the market so i'm going to go off and
create it myself
and so it made me do all these things
that i was afraid of that i wasn't good
at that didn't have natural talent and
it took me five years to get to my first
7 000 subscribers right think about that
journey now i wasn't doing it every day
i wasn't as hardcore committed i was
experimenting and playing with it a
bunch before actually taking it
seriously but i loved it
even though i love it like as much as
i'm afraid to get in front of the camera
or afraid to go and do a speech because
i don't want to disappoint people
i still love it i love it i love
serving i love helping people this is
what i this is what i need to do
and so even though i wasn't seeing a lot
of momentum or attraction at the
beginning even though all this stuff on
paper looked like it was against me and
i should quit and i should go do
something else
for whatever reason in my heart told me
i can't quit now i have to keep going
and just through sheer perseverance
and adjusting and developing the skill
set and getting better and becoming more
skilled i slowly got better
and now here we are you know my main
channel has over 2 million subscribers
and 300 million views and it's only
because i didn't quit on my dreams when
everybody else would have quit when it
comes down to it i think just as much as
we are a lighter company we are you know
a system level solution as an autonomous
vehicle company and partner to a number
of these different major automakers
where we're now working with seven of
the top 10 major oems at this stage you
know towards this vision of series
production and from a development
perspective it's it's progressing very
quickly so for us we're particularly
focusing in on the consumer vehicle as
well as the autonomous trucking market
um you know with uh uh and uh of course
in the case of mobile eye they they've
um uh they've dominated the landscape
when it comes to assisted driving system
for consumer vehicles they know what it
means and takes um but uh but really
we're the only solution that can
successfully enable autonomy at highway
speeds you know and that's really key to
enabling this to work uh of course you
know there there are other uh companies
other uh you know developments that have
happened from a lidar perspective you
know and that's where uh when when
during the r d stage you know you don't
always necessarily need the capabilities
of luminar off the back but when it's
time for series production that's where
we really come into play and you know
for these volume opportunities uh to be
able to uh to solve the problem so um
there's no question that i'm sure
there'll be a lot of great continued
developments but we're the only ones
that meet the spec to actually get into
production and uh now have the deals and
the scale to be able to do so every year
around february march i say the same
thing to myself and i set myself the
same goal let's just stop there right
and take a look at what i just said
because there's a real clue in that
first sentence
why does this goal pop up in march
the answer quite an obvious one because
summer is on the horizon
and you've got to ask yourself again
you've got to criticize yourself there
and say well why does summer matter well
because you know summertime is a time
where we wear less clothes we're a
little bit more vulnerable our bodies
are on show more and then you can ask
yourself okay so why is that relevant
well it speaks to the nature of my
motivation my motivation wasn't to work
out it wasn't to be healthy because i
want long-term health benefits or to or
to feel great about myself as
embarrassing as this is to admit my
motivation was so clearly
clearly
to look good for summer
let's just break that down a second
look good for summer
looking good as a goal is measured by
just one thing the public's opinion of
me
ladies opinion of me
that's what we call an extrinsic
external goal success of that goal will
be achieved when the public think i look
good the next part of that sentence
right was for summer the next part of my
goal was for summer which is a
measurable time frame so once summer is
over
the job is done so the motivation behind
that goal was both extrinsic and held
within a time frame so when i dropped
that social media pick of me topless in
mykonos or wherever i went this summer
mykonos and costa rica looking good
during summer and when i got the
compliments the likes the followers the
praise and when summer passed
unsurprisingly
so did my motivation
job done
my goal my reason my why was attached to
summer and also public opinion and both
had been fulfilled so as i pulled into
october and i tried to find the
motivation to go to the gym it was gone
going to the gym suddenly felt so
pointless to me and i had no idea why it
just did even when i managed to get to
the gym my workout was quite honestly
pathetic it was short it was like 25 30
minutes of me predominantly texting and
i didn't know why i just thought i
wasn't feeling great like you know like
a boat that had suddenly been unanchored
i was now just drifting unconsciously
without intention or real motivation or
without conscious realization into the
winter months into bad habits into fat
steve and the minute i realized this
this year i was able to completely reset
and sort of re-anchor my motivation into
things that were intrinsically
internally motivating and without time
frames i set myself the goal of going to
the gym just because it makes me feel
great i'm convinced that unless you feel
it
unless you feel it deep down in your
heart and you really understand it
you'll be doing lip service the whole
area of sustainability in my case i grew
up in madras in india where
at those days and even today i think
there wasn't much water in the city
and
we had so little water to live on every
day
that this whole notion of water
availability and water use
um was a crisis for me all my life i
didn't know a time when water was
aplenty until i came to the united
states okay
so water was seared into my head the
second is we grew up eating and drinking
a certain way
and all of a sudden i realized that as
you look around the world as you look
around all of the
health issues around the world
food played a very important role in
people's health and wellness so you know
one had to worry about that aspect too
and then my daughter went to work for
the environmental defense fund edf
and i got a whole new appreciation for
all of the environmental issues beyond
water
whether it was a carbon footprint
whether it was fisheries whether it was
any issue
she would actually show me all of the
statistics what it was doing to the
world overfishing in certain coasts or
plastic and oceans
and when you start to really feel these
issues and think about your kids and
their kids you ask yourself
what is my role as a steward of a large
company to make a difference in the
world through this incredible platform
that i have called leader leader of a
big company
that could either contribute to the
issues or help alleviate the issues
i knew that i didn't want to contribute
to the issues i had to start
helping the issues and to the extent
that society had changed and i was
perceived as contributing to some of the
issues i had to make a change to my
business model
and therein
was born our notion of performance of
purpose which is how can we keep
performing while changing the portfolio
while
fundamentally changing our environmental
footprint and then the third one which
is really the one that i'm most excited
about is what can we do for our
employees so that they can come to work
at pepsico feeling like
pepsico is a place where you cannot just
make a living but have a life so that
you can bring your whole self to work
the company treats you in a fair and
equitable way
provides you the support system to be
who you are to allow you to be who you
are and we embrace you completely
and so
performance with purpose is not a
corporate social responsibility program
it is not it is how we make money
because our belief is if we don't change
the portfolio we can't keep delivering
performance if we don't change our
environmental practices we won't get a
license from society to operate and our
cost goes up because we pay for water
we'll end up paying more for plastic
recycling so we have to do that and if
we don't get the best and brightest in
terms of people we won't be able to
deliver performance so performance with
purpose is how we make money not how we
spend the money we make which is what
corporate social responsibility is all
about so that's really what we're all
about we don't believe there's a tension
between product and business we believe
there's a staging which is in this
industry you don't have a business until
you have a product and in particular you
don't have a business until you have a
product that a lot of people want we
have this concept we use the term
product market fit which is basically
you have a product that the market wants
and you can tell because the market's
pulling the product and until you have
that time spent building the business
around the product is is pointless
because it's not going to go anywhere
like best case is going to be a zombie
there's a lot of companies are in the
valleys a lot of companies in the valley
and elsewhere that are you know 25 50 75
people they've got a product nobody
really wants it they sell a few every
quarter and they kind of eke out a
living and they go on for year after
year after year after year after year
and they never get anywhere they never
go public they never get bought
and people just basically collect
salaries and that's not what that's like
not what we want to do and that's not
what super you know super high potential
entrepreneurs want to do
so what we basically say is if you want
to build a big success you got to nail
the product you got to like it's got to
be a killer product it's got to be
something that has product market fit
when you have product market fit then
you build a company around it right so
then you build a sales force then you
start doing marketing and then you start
doing business deals then you start
expanding internationally and you do all
this other stuff i don't ever feel the
responsibility
um
to impress people with with my music i
do feel like i got to get in and do
do um my music to the best of my ability
you know and i feel like i'm my worst
critic you know
if
if i'm not digging it it ain't the [ __ ]
you know so
um the critics out there can basically
like kiss my ass straight up because
they know nothing about what goes into
this they're just people with a nine to
five behind a typewriter and a cd player
listening to it and critiquing it you
know you can't criticize
something that somebody's working real
hard on because that can like shatter
their whole [ __ ] you know it might be a
hit record in them you know that's why i
like
[ __ ] i'll be sending the source magazine
them critiquing records and
you know nobody can critique my unless
you've done
half of the stuff that i've accomplished
you know what i'm saying nobody can
critique it you know there's nothing
saying that i'm gonna make a i can smash
every time i go in the studio that's
what i set out to do but like i said
before you don't know what the public is
going to dig so
all the critics just need to shut up
until
they do
or try to do the sh that they're
criticizing i didn't tell anybody my
idea for one whole year
and it's very important to tell the
people that can help move your idea
forward
but i didn't share it for validation
purposes and no one had shared that with
me it was sort of a gut feeling
but one you know ideas are the most
vulnerable in their infancy the moment
you have them and this is the moment
that we always want to turn to a friend
a co-worker a husband and tell somebody
the idea
well the minute you tell somebody the
idea ego has to get involved and then
you end up spending all of your time
defending it and explaining it rather
than pursuing it
so i feel like more than anything the
reason why i'm not still selling fax
machines is because i kept it a secret
for one whole year and all my friends
and family can tell you all i would ever
they would say is sarah's working on
some crazy invention we don't know what
it is and after one year i sat them all
down i said okay guys
it's footless pantyhose
i mean you should have seen their faces
like
and out of love and concern i heard you
know if it's such a good idea why hasn't
somebody else done it and sweetie if it
is such a good idea you'd use your life
savings and the big guys might knock you
out of the water in six months
and until i had invested this much of
myself in this i think if i had heard
that a year ago when i cut the feed out
of my pantyhose that day
i'd still be selling fax machines as you
open yourself up to possibility the most
important thing i can tell you today
is to open yourself up to honesty
to telling the truth to each other
to being honest with yourselves
and to being honest about the world we
live
in if you watch children you will
immediately notice how honest they are
my friend betsy was pregnant and her son
for their second child son sam was five
he wanted to know where the baby was in
her body so he asked mommy are the
babies arms in your arms
and she said no no sam
baby's in my tummy whole baby
[Music]
mom are the babies legs in your legs
no sam
whole baby's in my tummy
then mommy what's growing in your butt
as adults
we are almost never this honest and that
can be a very good thing when i was
pregnant with our first child i asked my
husband dave if my butt was getting big
at first he didn't answer but i pressed
so he said
yeah
a
little for years my sister-in-law said
about him what people will now say about
you for the rest of your life when you
do something dumb
and that guy went to harvard
[Music]
hearing the truth at different times
along the way would have helped me i
would not have admitted it easily when i
sat where you sit but when i graduated i
was much more worried about my love life
than my career
i thought i only had a few years very
limited time to find one of the good
guys before he was too or before they
were all taken or i got too old
so i moved to dc i met a good guy and i
got married at the nearly decrepit age
of 24.
i married a wonderful man but i had no
business making that kind of commitment
i didn't know who i was or who i wanted
to be
my marriage fell apart within a year
something that was really embarrassing
and painful at the time and it did not
help that so many friends came up to me
and said i never knew that never thought
that was gonna work or i knew you two
weren't right for each other
no one had managed to say anything like
that to me before i marched down an
aisle when it would have been far more
useful
and as i lived through those painful
months of separation and divorce boy did
i wish they had
and boy did i wish i had asked them well
there's been so many challenges that
we've had and i think i think you know
one thing i talk to my team a lot about
is during those challenges you have to
really
be a leader and you have to lead with
conviction
so the toughest times which i've been
through many i mean i can just say one
time we were changing systems and we
didn't back up anything properly it was
maybe six years ago
it was a huge mistake so it was when
social media was really taking off we
were just starting twitter and
everything but it was maybe a six-month
problem and we had to make the decision
to be authentic and really talk about it
with our customer and
or not and the great thing is with with
social media transparency is super
important and being authentic and just
in general that's how our company is set
up but to have
to so we we decided to do that it was it
took us maybe eight months to get out of
a really bad place of going to new
jersey packing up back boxes ourselves
anyone everyone on our team i'm sure
some people over there including myself
on sunday nights at two in the morning
would be packing and shipping boxes and
we had no visibility so that was a
perfect um but that said we learned from
it we now have really good systems going
in working with sap which is a lot of
fun and um so there's been so many but
but i think it's um really learning from
the problems and mistakes is really the
telling part is how you go forward
you're 21 22 23 years old right you
don't have to figure it out right now
don't try
right you spend all this money
sorry
um
pain to learn now it's your chance to
get paid to learn you don't need the
perfect job
you just need to go somewhere where
you'll learn
and start to be exposed to different
ideas and now it's not like you know
when when greg 40 years ago was
graduating
and me five years ago
you know it was like get a career
and you know the pressure was get a
career go work for ibm or general motors
and get a pension those days are gone
people can't even pay their pensions
anymore and so you're a free agent
and you're always going to be a free
agent on the market you guys are the
kevin durants and lebron james
you know where you're always out there
and can go find a better situation for
yourself
do what's best for you what have you got
to lose like when i started my company
you know after i got fired by michael
yumeki
um
you know what was good how bad could it
be i would lose my motel sixth towel you
know
it was just like what have you got to
lose and yeah i understand there's
pressure from student loans and there's
a lot of conversations we can have there
right but you know you can get a job
that doesn't have to be perfect you can
learn at that job and you guys have the
pedigree you have the brains you have
the initiative to go out and try the
next job you know
you know the good news is the economy is
good enough that it may not be perfect
but you can go job to job don't look for
the perfect answer just look to get the
experience look to learn because all
these different exposures all the
different things you learn learning how
to learn
that's what's going to give you get you
excited and juicy for something that you
love because once you find something you
love to do
that's when the magic happens
because when you're when you're able to
find something you love to do then you
can start work focusing on how can i be
great at this
and like greg found out he was a great
networker i like to you know
play with technology and try to do
things first you know whatever it is
that you find about yourself then you
can try to be great at it and it's rare
when people quit things they're great at
you know and so trying those things so
that that's how i advise people don't
don't stress just go out and try
different things epictetus said
he is a wise man who does not grieve for
things which he has not
but rejoices
for those which he has
and that's gratitude isn't it
it's the very base decision that we all
have to make
are you grateful for the things you have
in your life or are you always wanting
more and trust me i get it
i understand people that strive for more
i understand people that want something
bigger and better but at the same time
if you allow yourself to only think
about what you don't have to only be
striving for something more that that
obsession will begin to overtake you it
will begin to corrode you
but ultimately it's a choice ultimately
at any time right now in this moment you
can stop
and think about what you have you can
put your attention on the things you're
grateful for and watch what it does
watch what it does in that instance the
way that it changes you the way that it
changes your chemistry your feelings in
a moment
can shift from negative and dark
to
beautiful
with nothing else changing around you
nothing but you deciding
that you're going to focus on the things
you're grateful for nothing but deciding
that there are things in your life to be
grateful for and that is a decision no
matter what is happening in your life at
any moment right now in the depths of a
depression in something going on
terribly in your life you can choose
right
now to think about the things you're
grateful for
the breeze
a smile from somebody kind a stranger
who holds open a door for you anything
but it's a choice
and as einstein said there are only two
ways to live your life
one is as though nothing is a miracle
the other
is as though everything is a miracle
and what choice are you making
what are you choosing to focus on right
now
do you let gratitude fill you up or not
and here's the critical part and i want
you to listen to this really well
whatever you decide whether you decide
we live in a world of miracles or
whether you decide we live in a world
devoid of miracles you are choosing one
thing to the exclusion of the other and
when you focus on something that you're
grateful for when you look at those
little moments in your life and choose
to see them as grand miracles even when
it is only a gentle hand on your
shoulder even when it's only a kiss from
somebody who you've kissed a thousand
times before even when it is only
holding the hand of somebody who needed
their hand held even when it's something
that simple
it really is a miracle that it really is
something that can fill you it really is
something that will change your
chemistry bring a connection between two
people allow you to see a grander vista
or even just open a window and look out
at the world and realize that you're
alive that this is all
a miracle that none of this is
guaranteed that every breath you take
could be your last
and in that
you can choose to cherish
what you have in that you can decide to
focus on
that you have a breath to take
and even when it's something that simple
when you train your mind to do that when
you train yourself to decide to see the
beauty in that
that nobody can ever take it away from
you get so many different opinions
paying attention to everything everybody
has to say about what about you what you
should be doing all of a sudden it can
start to paralyze you so over analyzing
you know and at the end of the day
entrepreneurship is about moving forward
taking action
you know what i mean teamwork we all
everyone should play a role on the team
everyone should have a voice you just
take one little instance
one little one one
thing in the game one steal one block
one shot one pass one thing that can
shape momentum that can completely
change the game from you losing or
winning
i think that was we talked about this
yesterday forget who it was
but somebody who knew kobe kobe was
watching a video of a kid in high school
who had like one single move that kobe
never saw he loved it so he showed up
early at staples center right from this
watching the kid in high school and he
started doing that move over and over
and over and over
right and his woman's like yo when are
you gonna stop
practicing that move and he said until
that's it until
you know what that meant
until he mastered it as meant as long as
it took for him to master that one move
he was going to continue to practice
that move
that's what you just have to do
you have to be early show up in that gym
every single day every single day put in
that work master your strengths know
yourself every single day keep pushing
forward right have that abundance
mentality make your team better every
single day
and watch how much starts manifesting
for you and your life personally and in
business and in your career
and then you'll have that true success
when is the last time that you cried
tears of joy that you remember oh man
and that wasn't too long ago that's
that's a more frequent occurrence for me
actually and as i've done you know a lot
of work on my life and it hasn't been
the external stuff that ever makes me
cry tears of joy it's not a big on at
success it's not something external that
happens it's really just sitting in a
moment it can be with a lover that i'm
sharing a night with and i'll just start
crying and just the experience of
enjoying that simple moment or laughing
with friends or i mean
it's actually a rather frequent
occurrence and that's one of the best
indicators for me that the path that i'm
on is
yielding the kind of fruit that i'm
really looking for and looking to forage
because i catch myself doing that all
the time i actually today i had a little
informal mentorship with one of my
employees and just as i saw that
breakthrough moment i saw that moment
where you know i was talking about her
working not on her business and not on
her career and on it but on her heart
and how that and she's like yeah it's a
big project and i go it's appreciation
and intentional appreciation so
one of the things i'm a crazy list maker
i make lists most people i know are kind
of people who make lists that person's
blowing your phone up right now i know i
just put on an airplane bus yeah
mike's doing that too and so i make
lists of stuff i got to do every day why
do i do that well it reminds me i want
to do but what i do
is self-confidence is the process of
keeping the promises you make to
yourself you've probably all heard me
say that lewis say that before but how
do you do that
well for me it's the visual
a delivery of it for me so if it says
like instagram live with lewis at 10 a.m
um
make sure i text pedro's coolion back
today whatever it is right i've got to
prepare a training i'm going to be doing
in a week i'm doing a las vegas tv show
today i got to prep for that and so when
i do something and i check the box i
don't just do it i intentionally go
nailed it nailed it got it got it and i
start banking these deposits in myself
so to speak of another promise kept
another promise kept another promise
kept that's something you could be doing
right now i had a little one last night
bro i'm going to share something with
you patrick schwarzenegger and i uh are
pretty good friends i know you know
patrick too and and i'm watching
patrick's
um
wait didn't i connect you guys
i think you you did connect this dave
you're right that's actually right i
connect with you maria schreiber that's
right
that's right that's perfect example of
of collecting oh my gosh i'm so glad you
just said that yes you did as a matter
of fact
and patrick's is good looking model
actor personal improvement guy you know
but he's so good looking he's like a
lewis house look-alike
and uh
but on his instagram
he's uh eating ice cream and eating cake
every single day well he can get away
with it whatever his metabolism is right
and i've been training hard but you may
think this is silly everyone but
i have had a little bit the last two
weeks of an ice cream problem dude i had
a whole thing a pint of ice cream last
night i'm with you man
dude i have been plowing ice cream in my
pie hole like so bad and i'm like so no
matter what i'm doing to work out i'm
like what is i never sit around and eat
ice cream i mean once a month or
something every damn night i'm on ice
cream and so last night this may seem
like a simple promise i'm not here's how
small life can get when you're in this i
woke up yesterday it was easter at
easter with my family i had to drive
back out here to the beach to work today
and i'm like no ice cream tonight
no ice cream
and it was on my list of things to do
that day was don't eat ice cream and i
got here last night and i did my work
all day and i do what you do i turn on
netflix and i'm like i'm gonna catch up
on ozarks for about an hour gosh no i
couldn't have the first two days yeah
which is gonna which is gonna turn into
eight hours of course right all of a
sudden it's one am but about midnight
i'm like
that ice cream sounds good right now
just a couple bites and then i'm like
well it's 1205 so technically it's the
next day you know you start playing
these games it's not actually that's the
problem anymore
but the point is i actually started to
walk to the freezer in the refrigerator
you may think this is stupid everybody
and i went no and i turned back around i
got a bottle of water and i sat and
watched another show and then i went to
bed but you may go that's nothing to me
that was another deposit in my
self-confidence inventory i'm keeping
promises i make to myself right so these
things may seem small but at 49 years
old this month
the reason i have went from having no
self-esteem no self-confidence
whatsoever
to where i am now which is pretty
confident is that is is that i i
started this process that i know works
which is promise kept promise cap
promise kept and these i've made
thousands of these deposits to where
when some one thing hits me that rocks
my self-confidence it doesn't take away
from the thousands of promises i've kept
to myself so just think about that what
are the small things you could be doing
how do we take the goals that you desire
how do we pretend it's six months from
now we're looking backwards and they
have them and attach an emotion to it so
it becomes a feeling so it gets stuck to
your subconscious so it becomes your
reality that's like manifesting on
steroids right but here's something on
the other side that most people don't do
what i'd like you to also do is i'd like
you to pick the goals that are left that
you're going to get done by the end of
the year because you're if you're
listening to me live as i'm doing these
this is half more than halfway through
the year if you if you're pushing some
off until next year that's fine but the
ones you're going to get done now i want
you to think about it six months from
now and you didn't achieve those goals
and you need to feel that too sit in it
it's six months from now and you're
looking back and go wow
another year went by
i'm still stuck in this job another year
went by i still didn't fix this
relationship another year went by i'm
staying in abusive relationship another
year went by i didn't spend the time to
try to date and meet someone new another
year went by i didn't register the url i
didn't make the phone call i didn't dig
into the course i didn't go through the
coaching
what will that emotion feel like and let
that bathe in that feeling bathe in
feeling like another year is gone bathe
in the fact of wow at this age i thought
i'd be further ahead because here's what
i know
some of you listen make moves based on a
bigger future you're moving towards
something better you're aspirational
you're inspired you see the bigger life
you see the bigger house the bigger
business the bigger success the bigger
significance in the world the bigger
impact
you see it it drives you
some of you listening right now that
scares you if that scares you then fine
you're a move away from person you want
to move away from a job you don't like
you want to move away from a bad
relationship you want to move away from
being broke you want to move away that's
fine some of you remove away people some
of you move towards and sometimes when
you get past the move away fear
then you can be a move towards person
that's the goals like move out of fear
and move towards pleasure listen what
drives all of us in life fundamentally
we all boil down to
we want to avoid pain and we want to go
towards pleasure so if that's you which
is everybody in the world use whatever
one it takes so again this is your
wake-up call you're if you're listening
to me like i said live kind of the week
i'm doing them it's more than halfway
through the year what have you
accomplished what have you let slip what
habits have you fallen back into where
have you let your life just go on
autopilot pick the goals you need to get
done this is your action call put them
on a new list put them on a list that
they're going to get done and push like
i said push some of them off but the
ones you push off have an action plan
for them starting next year get the ones
done now remember for future pace six
months from now they are accomplished
attach a feeling attach an emotion cry
if you have to get emotional laugh smile
pretend you're in a situation that that
lights you up but then also do the
opposite side pretend it's six months
from now and none of them got done
they're still in the same place how does
that feel all i know is this
is the last five years went by in a
flash how do you think the next five
years are going to feel and if you don't
make a change now if you don't take
action now what's going to be different
in your life i think the thing that
people misunderstand about success
is
they're looking for the easiest way to
get there
you know and it's funny how many people
books have you read or
i won't say promoted but had on your
show and everybody goes
five easy steps
ten steps to greatness yeah you know
eight steps to this and
those steps for success they're infinite
they are
infinite you cannot
count them
it doesn't matter how long you've been
doing it those steps are constantly
shifting
you don't know if they're there
sometimes you have to trust that the
next step is going to be there when you
can't even see it and sometimes when you
step on that step you go right into
quicksand but you got to be able to
pull yourself back out of it again so
everybody's looking for these steps and
there are no steps so steps never never
end and you just can't climb steps
sometimes you got to crawl though those
steps and you finally get to the top
and everything shifts and you're at the
bottom it's crazy
all right what does that mean sometimes
you're at the top and then you're at the
bottom again well you may get to the top
and you're like i'm here
and then you look back down and you look
up again you're actually on the first
step
you're on the first step again
and where you thought was the top is not
even the top it's the beginning wow it's
literally the beginning
of where you're supposed to be
and that's when most people just quit it
i just like it just drives me crazy
because everybody's like here
look at
i always people that i do the interview
with i always like to use them as an
example because people can relate to
that all right
you've been climbing steps for how long
to get to here
to get
i mean since starting this it's been
over eight years but the journey before
then
it was you know decades to build myself
to prepare myself for this and now i
feel like i'm just getting started right
exactly so you are
right exactly so all the steps that you
climbed just to get started yeah
just to get started and people don't
want to talk about those steps they
don't want to talk about those steps and
how difficult those steps are and how
many steps that you stumbled on and how
many steps you didn't even see and how
many steps that people placed in front
of you and they pulled and they pulled
them all pulled away people that you
were very close to people that you knew
that people that you thought that were
like hey these people actually have my
back except yeah they did have you back
but they were actually pushing you down
the steps
yes
no and
it's funny when you talk about those
things or people talk about them they
seem surprised
but you should know that in that path
all those things are going to be there
you went to tulane law school yes sir
and you graduate there and within nine
months tell them what happens because i
want you all to hear the ups and downs
of real life business in real life from
one of the most successful people in the
country so what happens at a law school
so out of law school i have two choices
for jobs and it's a recession right one
was to be a real lawyer oil and gas
litigator you know big money all i want
to do is be rich is why i went to law
school
and then the second was to work in the
internet and i got offered a job to sell
legal research online by west publishing
okay big big legal publisher and so i go
to my mom because you appreciate this i
go to my mom hey what should i do mom my
big advisor you know i grew up with a
single mom six kids and she without
blinking is like you need to be a real
lawyer because this internet thing is a
fad
so she calls the internet
and i always say because i like to teach
lessons biggest lesson of my life was
just because somebody loves you
doesn't mean they give you good advice
and i see so many people entrepreneurs
in relationships they ask for advice for
people that don't know anything my mom's
a second grade teacher right what does
she know about a beautiful soul but not
a technology expert no and if i would
have followed you know i think slowed
down or you know at least not allowed me
to have the acceleration i had so i took
the technology job right uh you know
single money hungry in a sales job in
the internet yeah and i made a fortune
nine months into it i had three goals
when i went to law school if i could
only pay back my law loans okay buy my
mom a home yep and buy my mom a car so
be very careful just because you love
them or they love you of thinking they
have some expertise in an area that you
don't right they probably don't and so
often times we take advice from the
wrong person derails our dreams so
that's less than one more thing too yeah
we end up resenting them which is worse
so all the people that love us most we
end up resenting them because they gave
us bad advice and meanwhile we should be
accountable because we asked the second
grade teacher for internet advice
and that's the worst part you have to
have a plan in your life for what's
going to happen to you when you hit your
60s and 70s and 80s and maybe by then
your 90s because people are living
longer all the time
how do you get a nest egg together well
the average salary in america is around
58 000 and so i'm going to give it to
you in a nutshell
you have to start saving in your early
years in your 20s 100 bucks a week
minimum minimum
but it's not just the saving aspect
you've got to invest that money so you
have to take that hundred dollars out of
whatever your activity is or you're
going to start a side hustle maybe
you're going to be a photographer maybe
you're going to be a writer maybe you're
going to do something else a separate
job where you can make at least
you know 100 bucks a week after tax and
you're going to invest it you're not
going to save it
you're going to invest it
saving is what you have in cash
investing is what you put into the
market
now the market is a volatile thing is
the first question you know
made reference to
and when you invest in the stock market
what matters is diversification you
don't know which stocks are going to go
up and down or when you don't know which
sectors of the economy are going to
outperform the others you have no idea
but if you look over a long period of
time what you see
is a market a stock market that returns
around six to eight percent a year
and if you start to put aside a hundred
bucks a week in your early years you're
going to end up with you know if the
markets do what they did for the last
hundred plus years you'd end up with
about a million and a half dollars when
you're 65.
that is really important you could have
the biggest craziest audacious idea in
the world but unless you can put one
foot in front of the other and make that
first step you're screwed and none of it
matters and again all it does is
it may allow you to you know
wrap yourself in some really elegant
rhetoric maybe it allows you to you know
be really followed on twitter and appear
at tech conference none of that matters
all of that crap washes out in the end
because if you suck you suck right and
you may be articulate but if you suck it
don't matter and you'll be revealed to
be a sham
what matters there is again is just that
ability to understand what that first
specific set of things
need to be
um
with that broader bigger goal in mind
um but if you can't put your first foot
in front of the other
um and you know what's amazing most
people can't
um because they get wrapped up in the
rhetoric of the vision and the mission
and all of this you know grandiose you
know blobbity blind that they screw up
and they're their own worst enemies i i
like revolution like i like disruption
right um but i'm skeptical that things
start that way i think things let's just
say ultimately five years from now we
look back and we think that there is a
massive sea change politically
in the arab world because of the arab
spring
that fruit vendor is self-immolated
because he was frustrated now maybe he
started a revolution but you know that
took courage to do what he did
that's not right or wrong in my opinion
but my point is you know that's an
example of how a revolution started with
you know a small
or not a small thing i mean it's a big
thing but um one thing that was
tractable within him and i think these
broad-based kind of like you know i
don't know gnarly expressions of like
how all of these huge crazy things can
happen
they happen over many many many many
many years these are massive tectonic
plates it all boils down to one person
doing one thing and i think that for a
lot of people that's hard still i'm
competitive
really with myself right
honestly like i every time i start an
album
i go and watch all of my performances
and i try to figure out okay what is it
that i could have done better or what
worked
and
really my references i go back to myself
and trying to
better myself so i'm really tough on me
more so than
than anyone else i'm not a competitive
person that walks in thinking about
other people and how i can compete with
them or especially not my husband or
maybe i just blank out the word doubt
[Laughter]
so
no i mean to be totally frank i doubted
us too so
i i thought we you know had maybe
when starting spacex maybe had a 10
chance of reaching orbit so
so you know to those who who doubted us
i was like well i think you're probably
right you know
i mean there were times
that i was told like
uh because i was taking the money that i
earned from from paypal and enrolling
into
to create spacex and tesla and and i
ended up spending it all it wasn't the
intention but
um
and and and uh almost both companies
went bankrupt frankly 2008 was a tough
year
um
you know it took us took us four
attempts just to get to orbit with
falcon 1.
um
and uh
so but a lot of times i was you know i
people would tell me this joke like how
do you make a small fortune in the
rocket industry you start with a large
one is the punch line
and i was like okay i already heard that
joke 12 000 times you know
so
anyway um and it was it almost came true
um
you know we just barely made it there
that fourth launch of falcon one that's
all the money we had for that fourth
launch
and then uh and that wasn't even enough
to to save the company we also then had
to win the nasa cargo resupply contract
um so that that came a little after you
know a little bit later all right
towards the end of 2008 uh those are the
two key things that that saved spacex
otherwise we would have we would have
you know
not made it so
um
so hey i think those doubters were their
probability assessment was correct um
but fortunately uh
vader smiled upon us and brought us to
this day
[Music]
if you want to know the seven daily
habits for massive wealth check out the
video right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe and
i'll see you there there are a lot of
things that are a waste of time you know
when you think about your life i think i
i often tell people
that i work with
if you can get
because people